- You know, we could all use a little bit
of encouragement now and again, right?
Well now some of you can get
it 24/7 on a brand new hotline.
Listen to this, this might
be my favorite story.
NPR reports Peptoc is a
hotline that delivers pep talks
from kindergartners.
Two, yeah, I know!
Two teachers named Jessica Martin
and Asherah Weiss put
together this art project
at West Side Elementary school
in Healdsburg, California.
And here, we need to dial a number,
this is the audio you get, listen.
- [Child] Please listen
to the following options
for encouraging messages.
If you're feeling mad,
frustrated, or nervous, press one.
If you need words of encouragement
and life advice, press two.
If you need a Peptoc from
kindergartners, press three.
- I know, I know.
- Oh my God!
- I knew you would love this.
(Drew squeals)
I know
Before the show I read
this story, so I called,
and I actually, I pushed
three for a Peptoc,
and it was like a group
of, what I think was like,
30 kindergartners and
they all said in unison,
"You can do it."
And I believe them! I do
believe them, I can do it.
But the teachers say, you guys,
this hotline is so popular,
they've gotten up to 900 calls a minute.
- Oh my gosh.
- Uh huh!
And you can keep it going.
You go to our website to
find out how you can support
their hotline costs, but
you can call this number.
I think it's so brilliant
because it shows the kids, like,
an unconventional way to make
a difference in this world
and that they are important.
(audience applauds)
You know what I mean?
That they can change grownups.
- Well, here's another
something that I really love.
We love to find little bits
of joy to brighten our day.
And it turns out every single day,
there is something to celebrate,
because every day's a holiday.
(audience cheers)
It's true, it's always
National French Fry Day
or Best Friends Day or Love Your Dog Day.
Well, guess what?
This Saturday was National Girl Scout Day.
- Aw.
- But we're keeping
the celebration going.
Please welcome the Daisy Troop
from River Vale, New Jersey,
Isabella, Riley, Ashlyn, and Riley.
- Hi! Aw!
Hi, hi, hi! You can put them right here.
Oh wow! Hi here!
Here, you can step up right here.
(audience cheers)
- Oh, hello girls.
- Hello.
- Hi, Drew Barrymore.
- Hi! How are you?
Now, will you please state your name?
- Isabella.
- Riley Hawks.
- Ashlyn.
- Riley Newnan.
It's so nice to meet you.
Interesting that both of
you Rileys have flowers
in your hair.
Is that a coincidence, is that
an accident or on purpose?
- Accident.
- We just put it in,
flowers in our hair,
because it thought it would look nice.
- Aw!
- Well, it does.
- And it does.
- It does.
(audience applauds)
- And you put a heart in your hair.
Do you like hearts?
- Yeah.
- I do, too.
And I love your pink bow.
- Thank you.
- I think it looks so pretty.
Which is your favorite Girl Scout cookie?
- Thin Mints.
- Mine too.
- A Thin Mint.
- Oh, well,
I cannot thank you guys
enough for coming here.
Now, I'd like to ask you
one more question, too.
What's your favorite part
of being a Girl Scout?
- I like to sell cookies.
(audience laughs)
- And what's your favorite
part of being a Girl Scout?
- Being nice
- Being nice.
- Aw.
- Oh, Riley.
Ashlyn, what's your favorite?
- Being nice.
(audience applauds)
- So cute.
You guys are this cute and
you brought us cookies.
Okay. You win the day.
You win the day, I have to say.
- Well thank you so much
for bringing us these delicious cookies
and all the hard work that you Daisies do
for your communities.
And Ross and I have a
little something for you.
- That's right.
We wanted to award you
these Drew's News badges
for taking a field trip
to come and see us.
There's one for you.
- We were wondering if we
could get these patches put
on your special clothes.
And also, we're gonna buy a whole bunch
of your cookies and make your sales go
woop, through the roof.
(audience cheers)
How does that sound?
- I've gone over 200 cookies
that I've sold.
- Good for business.
All right, and we're
also gonna put you guys
and your troop on our website so
that people can buy your cookies
or figure out how to
support and donate to,
you know, contribute to the Daisy Troop.
Well, thank you, Isabella,
Riley, Ashlyn, Riley.
Thank you so much for coming here.
- You're welcome.
- You beautiful Daisies.
Okay. This was my favorite.
May I have a Thin Mint?
Should we all have a cookie?
- Drew Barrymore?
- Yes?
- You're really beautiful.
- Which kind?
I'ma have this one.
- Wait, what did you say?
- You're very beautiful.
- I am?
- That's so funny,
'cause I think the very
same thing about you.
You're so beautiful.
Do you know where it's
the most important place
to be beautiful?
- Here and home?
- Yes. And inside.
- Your heart?
- Yes. In your heart.
Exactly. You all have beautiful hearts.
And this was my favorite
Drew's News we've ever gotten
to do because of you guys.
(upbeat music)